[Music]
okay
let's go another black game
and uh he's going to play d4 now what do
you guys want to see do you guys want to
see a king's indian
yeah let's play king's indian my main
opening
the love of my life king's indian
defense i have been playing this
consistently in the speed run in the
five minute speed run so the basic ideas
should already be familiar to those of
you who have been watching my stream
regularly
d6 and uh just to recap for those of you
who are new
what kind of opening is the king's india
there is a
descriptor that refers to a group of
players
who flourished around the 1920s who made
this audacious by those standards claim
that you can actually give up control of
the center and still be fine hyper
modern very good
why are we fine because basically the
hyper modernist claimed
that uh you could attack the center from
afar
using your pieces kind of as snipers and
using your pawns in a very tempered
fashion
not like a million pods in the center
but rather pushing one pawn into the
center but that one pun
is doing more than often times four or
five pawns are
did i scare you guys okay now what is
the main move here
which pawn are we using to strike at
white's center
e5 and d5 played by aditya by demon
i will explain afterwards why this does
not blunder upon there is a very simple
tactical justification the move c5 is
possible i have also played it many
times
but it is more in the style of benoni c5
offers a slightly different
bent on the position we want to maintain
the king's indian spirit
and d5 is a great way to this is the
petrosian
uh this is uh the petrossian variation
one second
saying kona thank you for the prime so
this closes down the center
which much like in the night or leads to
a situation where the sides usually
attack on opposite sides of the board
white generally attacks on the queen
side black on the king's side
but before we do any attacking we need
to complete our development
in particular we need to develop this
knight on b8 if we are to approach this
carefully we will see
that the move d5 creates a very nice
parking spot for this knight
and that parking spot is on c5 we can go
knight a6 or knight d7
and then we park the knight on c5 it
exerts pressure on the e4 pawn
and in order to avoid parking tickets we
can cement that knight after he defends
the pawn with what move
yeah so a5 is also possible but the move
is a5 what does a5 prevent
it prevents white from chasing away the
knight with b two to b4
this is one of the most foundational
ideas in the king's indian you will see
this all the time
that doesn't mean black cannot play
these positions without putting the
knight on c5 there are alternative ways
of developing
you can actually delay the development
of the knight
for a while but this is like the old
reliable approach
so aditya has to defend this pawn right
he he can't go b4 immediately because he
will give up his central pawn that is a
disaster
um so white has several ways of
defending at knight d2 is one of them
and now we go a5
to stop b4 is this hopefully this is
making sense
yeah now who can tell me
now that we have established the knight
on c5 how does black
actually begin the king side attack
it's all well and good to look at
white's king and say we're gonna
checkmate it
great talk all you want what are we
gonna do we are going to push that f
pawn out to f5
are we going to do it by jumping over
the night no we're going to move the
knight away
usually to e8 or h5 h5 is inaccessible
here because
bishop takes h5 but if white's knight
remained on f3 knight h5 would be a very
nice move
then we are going to push that pawn out
we're going to open the gate
we're going to push that pawn out and
then we're going to close the gate at
some point by pushing the knight back to
f6
applying even more pressure on e4
hope everybody is following so far this
pressure on e4 is often going to force
white to play
f3 and then we are going to lock up the
king side
with f4 watch this happen in the game
he's probably going to play f3
that's the classic reaction because the
pressure on this pawn becomes super
strong
and after f3 we close down the king side
with f4
but we do so temporarily we do so with
the knowledge
that we are going to reopen this with
what further idea
this is as classic king's indian attack
as it gets
what is the follow up here and
yeah now i wouldn't necessarily have
played a four in a real game
uh there are more nuanced ways of
approaching this but i want to showcase
the typical ideas yes g5
and g4 we are going to push out that g
pawn we are essentially going to attack
the base of this pawn chain
but before we do anything we need to
make sure that this knight is properly
secured
we need to make sure its seat belt is
fastened can we add a little bit yeah b6
adds a little bit of beef to the knight
we certainly don't want to go g5
immediately because after yeah we have
to take with the d-pawn
and that kills the integrity of the pawn
chain
so let's use that b-pawn let's delegate
it the very important task
of supporting the knight if white takes
on c5 we take with the b-pawn
and we have the vampire teeth new
concept
on the queen side this time which make
b4 very difficult to achieve
does this actually threaten anything no
c7 is not hanging
we can go ahead and play g5 okay
to those of you who actually play the
king's indian this is all review
but hopefully i am making a fair amount
of sense for those of you who don't play
it it's still a good idea to observe
how this stuff goes how are we going to
how are we going to actually
get g4 to work because right now it
would blunder upon
there are three main methods of
accomplishing
g4 one is as i explained to bring the
knight back to f6
the other less common but in my opinion
super cool and underestimated is a rook
lift lift the rook to g6 and then play
g4 and guess what if you get this done
then that rook is going to be very well
poised to take advantage of the g-file
once it opens up
thank you 200 bits yeah that is fan
being gold you're right
the third method less least common is to
play h5 generally this is not necessary
unless y plays h3 because why not
prepare g4 with a piece
why leave the knight on e8 where it's
passive
which one do you guys want to see here
all three are fine
but i want to hear the one that's
coolest
not rook we got to lift the rook guys we
got to lift the rook up now that doesn't
mean we can't combine these things
we can play rook to g6 then we can lift
the knight up but
that might not be necessary yeah we can
go g4 immediately let's
look at this rook x-raying the king this
is where the king's indian gets fun this
is where
you start looking for these very pretty
tactics that
are inimitably indelibly part of the
king's indian okay bishop f4 is panic
that is a creative move i see what he
wants but it's not going to i think he
wants this
yeah he wants to open up an attack on
the rook but this is just a daylight and
a dollar short
because for one thing we can move the
rook that's fine
but what's the simplest another 200
thank you
oh it was hanging oh my god he blundered
the bishop my god
i didn't even see that the bishop was
hanging yeah yeah you guys are right
that just hung the bishop but now we are
going to not miss that a second time
we're going to take the bishop
and then we're going to take on e5 and
be up a piece yeah
it's not a typical situation so i just
kind of blindly followed this
believe it or not i am after four hours
i am human
and now we're gonna take on e5 the best
kind of attack we are up a piece and we
are attacking
okay
okay so now
we we can take on f3 but we do not have
to rush with that
uh actually we we can't rush for that
because there's a very strong follow-up
move to this after queen takes f3
ding ding ding ding rook and queen on
the same diagonal
we have a bishop where do we put it we
put it on
g4 pinning queens of the rook we win
another exchange we are up a rook there
and then the g file is open so the game
is over
yeah that was nice well i am
commemorating 8
000 subs which i freaking cannot believe
we have 5 000 viewers and we are not
even stopping here so
and we got a five dollar donation from
the virox
as well which i had missed my apologies
so thank you so much to everybody for
this unbelievable level of support
8 000 and counting unbelievable
8 44. take stakes let's bring the queen
in
threaten checkmate pile up on the g-file
many ways to win this game this is the
most straightforward
okay now we have an explosive way
to capitalize on the pressure we are
exerting
do not forget that pons can be
full-fledged attackers
upon f3 he can't take it because of the
pin if he doesn't take it then we will
take g2
exposing his king even further and
leading to quick
checkmate okay
so yeah most of this will be on youtube
the 10-minute speed run that we've been
doing in kind of impromptu fashion
i will decide how to incorporate that
but every day a new video comes out on
the speedrun 1850 is where the youtube
is
at right now um now
by the way in this position let's finish
this game though
uh it's very important to indicate well
actually what
what what should we how do we actually
end this game
what's the simplest yeah the simple
bishop d4 blunders the bishop right he's
yeah i would just take take and take
that's the simplest right no need to
reinvent the wheel here
and uh we should notice that if this
queen on d1
were to cease its control of the g1
square
we would have a tactic where we
basically force the king out of g1
via this move or that move and then we
promote a new queen and ladder check
made him with rocket h6 that's a common
technique by the way
and the issue with white is that and
that's exactly what's going to happen
here that's a very pretty move queen h2
but it's very typical
then we are going to promote a queen and
the new queen is going to be better than
the old queen because that king is going
to be
driven out of its little cocoon on g1
and the simplest is queen g3 checkmate
that's the fastest
good game promoting to a rook would not
be good
all right great introduction here to the
king's indian
and i've talked about it a fair amount
in the five-minute speedrun so i'm not
going to
rehash everything time and time again
but um where did a dts start going wrong
so d5 is a legitimate move that's the
petrosian variation now d takes e5 the
exchange
if white takes on e5 then we should
notice that the knight is in the
crosshairs of the bishop
which means we should start looking for
discovered attacks against that knight
which means that we should move this
knight not just anywhere but to a square
where it
where it produces the most damage right
and the most damage is is produced by
taking the pawn on e4 restoring material
equality
and black is doing great here because
he's got this diagonal
and he's got this very juicy d4 square
for the knight as well
okay so this is good for black
now um d5 is possible the main line is
just to castle here
and retain the tension d5 closes up the
center and
a detail played very well up until
i mean this is fine but here aditya you
started to sort of
make these slow moves the problem in the
king's indian is that it's very very
deceptive it's hard to play with white
because it may not seem like white isn't
in any danger whatsoever the king looks
perfectly safe it's the calm before the
storm
many games have been lost like this so
your moves kind of make sense
yes you're improving your position but
you are letting me develop
my attack without really starting
anything on the queen side now in order
to
make progress on the queen side white
must
find a way to get this b4 pawn break in
now you guys might look at this and say
no problem i'm just going to play a3 and
then i'm going to play b4 what's the big
whoop
well there is a big wolf what does black
have in response to a3 that is the move
a4
using on pissant weaponized on passant
if you go
before here comes the opposant and this
is a disaster because if you take on b3
you drop the pawn
but even if you weren't to drop the pawn
the effect of b4
has been completely demolished by this
amphison
so in order to actually do this and
circumvent
the a4 idea white must play b3
then a3 the idea is that a4 is now met
with b4 and there is no one poissant
because the pawn has only moved one
square then
you are still not ready to play before
why because mr undefended rooks here is
going to complain
so we have to either move the rook out
of the way but first we need to defend
this pawn let's play f3
then we move the rook out of the way or
we can defend the rook by developing the
bishop
and we are finally ready to play b4
which chases the knight away which in
turn
creates a kind of domino effect because
once the knight is gone from c5
white can himself play c5 which is the
main way that white makes
progress in the king's indian many games
have been won this way
that is where the king's indian derives
its reputation as a very very sharp
opening white
has this incredibly strong queen side
attack and
i didn't faithfully represent how black
would play black will attack on the king
side and it produces these incredibly
chaotic positions
um so a lot of people at this point
if i'm reading the chat right some of
you
are definitely thinking like wait a
second so black is going for checkmate
and white is going for like a queen side
attack how is that
fun for white i mean why is anybody
playing this with white well
the reality is uh in a certain sense
the bar for succeeding on the queen side
is lower than the bar for succeeding on
the king side
um delivering checkmate is very hard
particularly since white's
king side is not without defenders on
the other hand
for white to actually break through and
start winning everything on the queen
side is not that difficult it requires
only like four or five moves
and then black is already going to be at
the gates of hell that d6 fund collapses
and then like dominoes everything kind
of falls so
you can think of it this way what
benefits black is the fact that
uh black is going for checkmate so black
can sack a bunch of stuff
and give checkmate what benefits white
is the fact that white's attack
runs more smoothly and is easier to
achieve than black's attack you get this
counter balancing factor
and you get absolutely fascinating
positions in all lines of the king's
indian
so what the king's indian teaches you to
do is so many different things to play
chaotic positions
to play both defensive and attacking
chess at the same time
basically fighting off an enemy with one
sword fighting off an enemy with a
shield
and fighting a different fight with a
sword that is one of the hardest skills
in chess because most people have a
one-track mind
they are either defending or attacking
at the same time sorry they are either
defending or attacking at one time
it's very hard to do both at the same
time and to do it well
and yet that is very necessary to play
the king's indian
well in light of this none of this
should be surprising in g5
lifting the rook up to prepare g4 if
white had gone h3 to stop g4 we would
have simply gone h5
to reinforce that threat the king's
indian is extremely popular at the high
level and has been for many many years
yeah i forgot this bishop was hanging
no i mean timor rajaba is one of the
world's leading specialists in the
king's indian
and uh he uh you know he just won the
the air things open so king's indian is
probably
the most popular opening among
grandmasters uh on a sort of per capita
basis i think
and uh it's not necessarily the best
opening it's just one way of playing
but it is probably the only way to
guarantee
virtually guarantee a very sharp
position right out of the opening
okay 1400 okay let's go e4
let's go e4 and uh let's see
what happens here it depends on the
position
spassky was a goon spassky was an
absolute good yeah yeah definitely thank
you okay
so um
what opening shell we play knight f3
alright uh we can play many different
openings we can play the scotch
we can play the italian but um
i'm going to show you guys
now let's play um let's play the scotch
in fact
let's actually play the scotch gambit
now the scotch gambit is like a cross
between a scotch and an italian
it is a opening that often slips through
the cracks i highly recommend it for
those of you
who play the evans gammon and are
looking for an alternative it is
super dangerous at this level it is
actually played by grand masters it is a
very legitimate weapon
at the very highest levels as well at
somewhat lower levels of course it can
bring quick victories because there's a
bunch of traps in this line
now essentially think of it and d6
played by will is i actually played this
myself with black
it leads to a slightly worse position
it's a good way to avoid the traps
the way that you guys should think about
this is it's like in italian why do you
play this move first you play this move
largely to open up your access to the g5
square
because in many lines this knight g5 or
bishop g5
is a very important aspect of it so will
decides to give back the pawn
and instead open up the diagonal for his
bishop we of course have
a very nice position here we have better
central control we have a bishop on c4
kind of like a good scotch uh and uh
we've recovered the sacrificed pawn
after the game i'll talk a little bit
about the theory of the scotch gambit
let me just write this down
one moment
okay let's take a shot of the sketch
yeah so will thinking about how to
develop his pieces i mean
he shouldn't overthink it now
would it be a good idea according to our
logic for black is okay let me put it
another way should we be afraid
of black taking on d4 as white should we
be afraid of the queen being in the
center no
and the reason why is that he doesn't
have another knight on b8 to put on c6
that queen on d4 is going to be
perfectly well placed in fact i'm pretty
sure we had this position
through a different opening in the speed
run maybe through the philidor move
order
where black is super solid extremely
solid
black has a nice you know pawn here that
restrains the e pawn
you should not try to lunge at black's
throat here
you should rather nurture your advantage
bring all the pieces out and
enjoy the fact that white has a nice
space advantage and nicely placed pieces
who can propose for me a developing move
and this is where things get very tricky
this is actually a much trickier
position than it appears
so uh prepare to put on your tactical
hats now f4 is a little premature
because we haven't developed our queen
said you know
i am a little bit worried about f4 oh my
god five bucks from just a twitch smurf
low halo games are a bigger mess than
capitol hill
yeah perhaps perhaps thank you sorry
yeah i don't i turn off the alerts
in the meantime so bishop e3 or bishop
g5 both seem very natural
but both of these moves end up being
susceptible
to two different types of tactics
there's a lot to explain here
let me try to be quick and then
afterwards i'll explain in more depth
bishop e3 allows a tactic that i have
indicated many times
in the speed run which is what first of
all knight g4 is unpleasant
first of all knight 4 is unpleasant but
second of all it is the move
knight takes e4 what isn't that a
blunder no
knight takes e4 now d5 to recover the
piece and that leads to mass
trades and we don't want mass trades so
here's what i want you guys to do can
you give me a move that permanently
prevents black from having this in his
pocket
when we make bingo bishop b3 and guess
what we put the bishop on a defended
square
that's essentially what we are doing and
we're moving it away
from the wrath of the pawn the move
f3 i completely understand why you would
play it but it is a little bit weakening
you know never play f3
but no f3 is possible f3 would be a very
viable alternative since
you could move the bishop out to e3 and
cover immediately the diagonal weakened
by the move f3 so f3 would be also quite
good but
here i want to play this without f3 i
want to play bishop b3 and i want to see
what will is going to do here
and we get a raid just dojo live
rain and party 50 thank you david i'm on
the tail end of my stream doing my final
speed run game
of the day 8 000 plus subs
today amazing stream we are rounding it
off
but thank you so much appreciate the
raid
okay 95 is a bit of an odd move because
yeah now
this walks right into a um
i know over a thousand subs it would be
insane
we don't need to play h3 we can strike
this knight on e5
is not stable yeah let's get it out of
there and we control more of the center
the reason i dismissed f4 here is
because it doesn't come with tempo
and now that the bishop is on a safer
square f4 is a little bit more justified
it's a little bit safer
now we have more control of the center
we still probably want to complete our
development at some point
although the immediate bishop e3 might
still run into knight g4
so we have some things to solve here but
we will
okay bishop g4 this is the kind of move
which
should not intimidate you thank you
camelot for the prime
because it attacks the queen but that's
literally all it does that bishop can
actually get
into a lot of trouble where should we
put our queen well as we know the way we
think about such positions we want to
put the queen on a square where it is
also potentially doing something right
we only have two squares d2 well d2 can
be tossed out immediately
that's just a super awkward move d3 is
under control of the knight so queen to
e1 because we can also bring the queen
later to the g3 square we are not
blocking the bishop
you know sometimes you really can reason
with very simple logic there is nothing
wrong with that
simplicity uh does not mean
you know that you are somehow missing
the point of the position sometimes the
correct logic is simple logic
and simple does not mean easy
oh my yeah oh i thought i missed the 35k
tone i was like i don't know
okay now we are anticipating that we'll
we'll move his 90 does
but now i indicated well queen d2 would
basically
block the bishop and think of it this
way the queen on e1
is also good because it could later move
to g3 and x-ray the king
yeah so h3 and the bishop is in trouble
um will does have a way to
i think tactically extricate his bishop
but let's see if he plays it and
it doesn't entirely solve all of his
problems now you guys want to wait a
second
trapping the bit doesn't he have bishop
b6 if he goes bishop b6
what happens which way do we take that
bishop we not only win upon
we win more than upon we win the
exchange
how
not f5 because then he has this way out
by we play bishop takes e6
f takes c6 and knight takes e6 for king
queen of the rook
okay um if he goes bishop h5
then the method by which we trap the
bishop is very straightforward we push
the pawn out to g4
bishop drops back to g6 and we play f5
cornering the bishop
some of you might be looking at this
line and saying well how do i know that
it's justified to move another pawn in
front of the king
the way that i know this is that black
simply doesn't have any firepower near
the king side
and in addition winning a piece is a
pretty significant event
third thirdly we can always bring the
queen in to g3 and the queen can also
fulfill the defensive role
simply lending some shelter you know
putting the umbrella over white's king
will decides to give up the bishop
immediately
out of curiosity who can spot the way
that i just referenced to
extricate this bishop without losing
material
the move that you should really be
looking for here is a counter attack
good
c5 counter attacking the knight and if
the knight moves away
first of all the bishop can take the
knight but second of all the bishop can
then drop back to e6 and of course
the e6 square is no longer covered
so this is a little bit of panic because
now
now we have an additional square for the
night which was not
particularly effective previously very
important thing to do do not just
automatically
submissively drop the knight back to f3
think about how the position has changed
as a result of a trade
in this case as a result of us winning
the bishop vf5 square has cleared off
for the knight knife f5
look at all of our pieces now are going
to be aimed at the king side so in
addition to our extra piece
we are about to develop if i'm reading
this situation right an
incredibly incredibly powerful attacking
mechanism okay
man man man what a stream
no position is position is better for
ross up a piece
if we didn't have an extra piece white
would still probably be better
okay what should we do yeah so e5 is
also great in fact e5 might even be
better
yeah i actually love see queen g3
runs into one small problem which is
how is black going to defend against the
checkmate threat
it's not going to be knight h5 that
knight on h5 is going to be very flimsy
uh the move is actually g6 and that's
again sets up a kind of biting on
granite situation
where if we then play queen takes g6 of
course the h1 takes because this spot is
pinned
um but um that is actually not the best
way to play e5
is really good because we essentially
the way you should think about a move
like this
is you're opening up a second front
you're opening up a second front
by which i mean you are holding in your
pocket yes maybe later we'll play queen
g3
but we are also attacking down the
middle and when you combine these two
things you'll just see that we're
crushing black's position like a bug
thank you eric uh eric
uh her on music now knight h5 worry not
yes we cannot play queen g3 no big deal
what can we do how do we fulfill the
center
attack noticing that the bishop on b3
can be actualized
with the move e6 it's sorry it's
potential can be actualized to the movie
6.
this is crushing we're attacking the
knight the pawn the bishop is going to
fall as well it's also type
two undefended piece you guys can see
that type two undefended pieces are
important to notice
this is something that i actually did
notice when i played knight f5 i made a
mental note to myself wait a minute
it's fish money seven guess what type
two undefended and what's defending at
the queen what do we know about the
queen as a defender
queen is not a very good defender so by
opening up the e file we are also
helping exploit the weakness of the
bishop
type 2 undefended piece a piece that is
protected by only one
other piece it does not include pawns
type one undefended is what we
traditionally think of as an undefended
piece
which is a piece that like the knight on
h5 is not protected by any other pieces
okay so knight on h5 is type
two sorry type one knight d7 and bishop
and e7 are both
type two undefended so black's minor
pieces are not in a very good way here
yes type one undefended is the same as a
hanging piece you can call it that as
well
okay so here of course oh actually if
you guys want to be fancy you know what
we can do
okay what what what is the like obvious
move here
and then i'll show you guys something
funny so the obvious move is of course
ef7 but we can actually take the bishop
first if we want
because if he takes on e7 now we play e
takes f7 there
and we actually win the queen even if he
plays rook f7 that rook is going to be
pinned
so we can take his queen so we can play
this little sneaky move just
transposition of moves now we play e
takes f7 the queen is defending the
knight we are up
two pieces and look at this pawn black's
king
funnily enough is safe for the time
being but
that is not going to bring black any
kind of relief
the rest is a simple matter of
consolidating our pieces making sure
that we are not
uh playing in two cavalier fashion
making sure that you know the white king
is also not too safe so
you always want to maintain control over
the position
wow next hope i that warms my heart to
see comments like those i'm so happy
uh that you are learning and welcome
welcome to the community
uh so so happy to see so many people
getting better
and i am honored to play a very small
part in that so
that is another uh
on non-trivial reward from streaming to
such
an awesome community okay so queen b6
creates
a standoff with a king or an x-ray
and when you identify x-rays you like
you can't just stop there you need to
ask yourself
okay is there actually a threat that is
associated with that x-ray and here
the answer is yes what is that threat
how do we prevent it there are several
ways to prevent it
yeah so bishop b3 so first of all c4
check right c4 check is the annoying
threat
but other than bishop e3 and you guys
should think of this and tie it into the
ways that we have
of um stopping a threat so how do we
stop a threat
the traditional way is to
make that move ineffective but we can
also try to take out the piece
that is that is essentially creating the
threat itself
if you guys see what i mean so here what
this translates to we can play a move
like bishop e3 or queen e3
but that's a little bit passive because
then this piece
has really only one role which is to
reduce the x-ray
but instead we can try to target this
queen by targeting this queen we are
essentially targeting
the cause of the problem rather than the
symptoms you guys are proposing some
good moves
95 is great but there is a move that
nobody has proposed yet
arab one two three four thank you for
the sub spirit
hem which is the move queen e6 using the
queen trade
as a weapon look at what this move
accomplishes if you go c4 check he loses
the queen
black can drop his queen back to a7 and
keep the x-ray
but then the queen on e6 is beautifully
positioned look at how it's right in
black's grill
and whatever black does then we can play
bishop e3
and the queen essentially has made its
way in front of the bishop
then all of our pieces are perfectly
placed so we're simply improving the
position of the queen
a queen trade plays entirely into
white's hands here because we're up two
pieces
that doesn't mean we have to do that
there were many possible moves knight d5
is great even king h1
a couple of you proposed nothing wrong
with that queen before play by black now
we have uh gotten rid of the x-ray which
means we can focus on completing our
development
without having to worry about these
ideas what should we do how should we
complete our development
and yes i'm talking about completing our
development
even though we're up two pieces that
does not change the fact
that you need to adhere to basic opening
principles and g5 is now
the most accurate i think an active
square for the bishop i might say
so yeah he can give us a check on d4
yeah bishop h6 is possible but
as my coach would always say you are not
writing a book
uh during you're not trying to write a
tactics book during a tournament you're
trying to win games
there was an australian international
master uh by the name of purdy
who echoed that sentiment he had a quote
that i like
he said you know you play in a
tournament uh to
win points not to paint pictures and
that's not entirely true it's good to
paint pictures and win points
but you should not paint pictures at the
cost of not winning points especially
when you're up a bunch of pieces
resist the urge to do something crazy
when easy does it
okay it's good to play beautifully but
you shouldn't play beautifully
when that in any way sort of jeopardizes
an otherwise simple win yeah we can
bring the queen back now to e3
again offering the queen chain and again
forcing this queen tossing it around
then we can bring the rook into the open
file
okay
so both of these sentiments are the same
it might seem weird or
disingenuous hypocritical for me to be
saying this but i don't believe it is
um because beauty comes from
first and foremost i think necessity uh
what is that expression necessity is the
mother of all inventions right
so what makes something truly beautiful
i think one of the
qualifying factors this is by the way
guys one of the reasons why i think the
opera game is so overrated
is because it was not necessary to do
the kind of stuff that more if he did it
was very pretty
it was very instructive but black played
so badly
that white had multiple simple methods
of achieving a huge advantage
and i think what distinguishes a game as
truly beautiful is the fact that the
beautiful sequence was also
necessary was the only way to accomplish
what needed to be accomplished
okay so he gives up the rook and resigns
good game will
and uh okay so the scotch gambit
before we end a quick overview so
there are actually two main moves that
black has here the first is to defend
the pawn
the second is to counter attack white
spawn
if knight f6 then white goes e5
and attacks the knight and here black
has a super important
counter-attacking move without this move
the scotch gamut would be refuting e45
that is the move d5 attacking the bishop
very common idea this the point
is to occupy the center and to open up
the light square bishop and then you go
bishop b5
you get this very sharp and very
interesting pawn structure which i will
not delve into right now
but if you're on the lookout for a new
opening this
is very worth very much worth
considering even if you're rated 2 000
i'm telling you this is played at a
grand master level so this is a very
legitimate opening that's number one
number two is bishop c5 here y plays c3
and this is a very venomous move because
if d takes e3
what can white do in this position using
a concept
we have outlined time and time again
undefended pieces the bishop on c5 is
undefended
the muppah most popular wrong answer is
queen to d5 you might look at this and
say ah
fork but before you play a move that
seems to win
via a fork you ask yourself can my
opponent make a move
and defend against both threats at the
same time queens are actually good at
that very specific
subtask of defending queen e7
and unfortunately if you go bishop g5
black and go f6 and black has warded off
the attack c takes b2 is also a huge
threat
actually cb even here so for that reason
we
we simply change up the move order we
take first on f7
now we give a check and we essentially
can take the pawn
equal material but black is a very very
weak king permanently
and white white has a very fun position
white is not winning here
but this is not considered a good line
for black this is super fun
this is not pre-recorded no okay
um so for that reason knight f6 here is
the main move
and then you get this again e5 d5 and
you get a similar position to the knight
f6 line
again very rich very tactical very
interesting
so d6 is fine i played this myself uh
and black gets a very solid position so
here again bishop b3 right stopping
knight takes e4
95 i think is the root of the the
problems
i think that the way to play this with
black is
you don't need to well first of all you
can take on d4
and develop the bishop to e6 when you
are are cramped
when you are cramped uh it's a good idea
sometimes to trade off a couple of
pieces to lighten the burden a little
bit
particularly this bishop on b3 is a
beast white is better
white is a nice position but black is
super solid because black has no
weaknesses
after 95 f4 bishop g4 i think is almost
the decisive mistake i think that
probably the best thing to do is
my old coach gregory kind enough very
strong grandmaster would always say
to say sorry just go back to c6 yes
f4 is is nasty thing to allow but black
is still not lost black is still very
solid that pawn on d6
acts as a kind of barrier to white
playing e5 so still
more or less fine if daniel were to make
an opening course what's your favorite
that's actually a really good poll let
me
write down the info here king's indian
yeah i think king's indian is starting
to win
left arms and that's actually something
that
would be a labor of love for me because
i need to formalize my analysis in many
different lines this would actually help
me
yeah so i think king's indian if i do
make an opening course that might be
the one that i kind of settle on as it
seems
from the from the pole uh
okay ooh clover of crab is online
yeah king's gambit is fine uh but not
extraordinary and after bishop g4
the last uh idea was to play c5
attack the knight on d4 force it to move
and then either take on f3 and at least
you don't lose the bishop
or drop the better yet drop the bush
back to e6 nasty position for black
weaknesses all over the place but black
is not down material black and
more or less survive here okay
um thank you for the youtube shout out
every sub counts on the youtube i really
appreciate
not only people's support on twitch but
also on youtube we're at 115k subs
my goal is to hit a million one day and
uh
you know this this really really helps
so thank you for the
incredibly positive feedback on the
speedrun videos
and asia orbit subbing at tier one
thanks for that as well
well i don't really i don't know i'm not
a big background art kind of person
i like the chessboard that's basically
it
okay uh learn scotchgame yeah
so at this level you kind of do need to
learn
the theory of these basic responses at
least just a couple of moves
you don't have to go crazy if you just
know to play d5
you're going to get a decent position
and here improvising from a position of
strength
allows you to get a playable position
the problem happens when you really
don't know what to do from the very
start
then it can be hard to like find on your
own something like this even for a
grandmaster
okay so maurice ashley had had a lecture
talking about e4 being a slightly
overwritten not true i don't think he
said exactly that i i mean i didn't see
that lecture but
could you perhaps explain the context in
which he said this because
i don't think anybody thinks that e4 is
a better move than d4 other than bobby
fischer
e4 being best by test but even he kind
of said it in an allegorical kind of way
e4 is like the
romantic move but nowadays uh d4 and e4
are considered largely equivalent even
knight f3 and c4
uh have their place
yeah i think that hey joe i i think that
what
maurice might be trying to imply here is
that and and this is a point i would
totally 100 agree with e4
does not like always you cannot
guarantee
that uh you will get like super tactical
positions in checkmate your opponent
ever you need to be prepared for
positional battles
even in e4 openings you can't gambit
your way
to to grand masternom you need to try to
become
well-rounded from a relatively early
stage so maybe i'm not without putting
words in his mouth
maybe that's partially what it is he's
trying to to get it and i think that's a
great point
okay guys